okay next game Lou has Mia poppy played
him yesterday and accused me of computer
cheating
it's always nice if people think their
opponents can only win with some help
oh he's telling me try and use your head
this time instead of a cop I love those
people
yeah is this one I'm not sure about the
line I guess this is some this is normal
and I cannot play Bishop h6 with us
because this Bishop is a nuisance really
you know I don't have any detailed
knowledge about this just what I've seen
in some Grand Master games
I really want to play Bishop h6 asserted
ridiculous to sacrifice this pawn well
maybe it is
he can just you can just take I like the
idea though I'm not sure how to get
counterplay otherwise maybe I take here
first to prevent him from opening them
yeah I had the idea of Bishop III so now
f5 or is this ridiculous
should I fall I think I cannot go
without a 5 in the long run
yeah white looks to be better on the
queenside of course it is ready to play
a5 I really need to get something going
there maybe I should just take
tonight that fire he takes with the
piece he can take with the pawn though
maybe it's an idea
by the way I played King ej2 to get the
night from you seven to f6
yeah
yeah it's looking dangerous for black he
can just play five I think how about I
can take years you don't he doesn't have
a ruby for be seven maybe hmm it's not
entirely clear maybe its own it's okay
for black actually
try to I could I could try to sacrifice
here it's is this an idea well I can't
sit still all day here in this position
and get murdered on the queenside
this doesn't look entirely correct but
our kids it's a lot of pieces around the
king maybe this is possible
okay how to get more pieces over there
it's also got rook rook to g1
Jim maybe just taking only three and
then 94 to have Queen h4 look this looks
a bit strange to give up an attacking
piece but I need to get the Queen
involved it's certainly not so easy to
play for white yeah this looks sensible
but but what about rook f3
what what is he doing about it about
this I can just take you three there or
d3 is hanging okay but taking now in
Queen g5 this is a temple I think
I win this game II will accuse me again
I'm I'm 100% sure
yeah it's telling me it's telling me
again I played with the computer it's
it's amazing
it is as if it was that it he never got
mated in the Kings Indian it happens all
the time
people just shove the pieces toward the
King and it's ridiculous and he really
thinks he is telling me it's telling me
all the time oh well
I never respond to those people that
just get got a problem time warning
so no just drew page three coming quite
results yet was was just just a good
game but what can I say I think at least
from a practical point of view it was
very interesting but as ever could could
check with with the comp this time
really oh he's giving he wants to take
on h3
with a bishop and giving me a winning
advantage okay ah I see he wants to
check with the bishop and then play
queen c8 if he takes I didn't see that
at all this looked interesting also
gifts this is good for Black Knight h5
this also amazing this really seems to
be playable we should be three it was
also wants to play this yeah I'm playing
all the computer moves really okay yeah
but but it's easy it's easy to find you
just put the pieces towards the king so
I guess h3 was was a mistake then simply
yeah interesting game